Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to give instructions
to Google’s new self-driving robot,
and see if it is smart enough to deal with these
nasty tasks. Look at that. There is no way, right?
Well, with our current tools, I am not so
sure. But let’s be ambitious, and think about
a possible Dream Scenario for a self-driving
robot. For this, we need 3 puzzle pieces.
You see, whenever we talk about self-driving
techniques, usually, the input is an image,
and the output is a question
like, okay self-driving car,
what would you do next? But note that the input
is not a sentence. These AIs don’t speak English,
so puzzle piece number one. Language. For a
possible solution to that, have a look at OpenAI
and NVIDIA’s AI’s that can play Minecraft, and
here comes the best part: they also understand
English. How do we do that? Well, we can
use OpenAI’s earlier technique called GPT-3,
which has read a huge part of the internet,
and get this, it now understands English.
However, we are not done yet. Not even close.
Puzzle piece number two. Images! If we wish it
not only to be able to understand English, but
to understand our instructions, it needs to be
able to connect these English words to images. It
knows how to spell “stop sign”, but it hasn’t the
slightest clue what a stop sign really looks
like. So, we need to add something that would
make it understand what it sees. Fortunately,
we can also do this, for instance, using the
recent DALL-E AI that took the world by storm by
being able to generate these incredible images
given our text descriptions. This has a back and
forth understanding between words and images, this
module is called CLIP, and it is a general puzzle
piece that can fortunately be reused here too.
But, we are not done yet. Now, puzzle piece number
three. Of course, we need self-driving. But make
it really hard for this paper - for instance,
train the AI on a large, unannotated self-driving
dataset, which means that it does not get a great
deal of help with the training. There is lots of
data, but not a lot of instructions within this
data. Then, finally let’s chuck all these three
pieces into a robot, and see if it became smart
enough to be able to get around the real world.
Of course, there is no way, right?
That sounds like science fiction and
it might never happen. Well, I hope you know
what’s coming, now hold on to your papers,
and check out Google’s new self-driving robot,
which they say has all three of these puzzle
pieces. So, let’s take it out for a ride, and
see what it can do in two amazing experiments.
First, let’s keep things light. Experiment number
one. Let’s ask it to recognize and go to a white
building, nice, it found and recognized it. That’s
a good start. Then, continue until you see a white
truck, now, continue, until you find a stop
sign. And, we are done! This is incredible,
we really have all three puzzle pieces working
together. And this is an excellent application
of the The Second Law of Papers, which says that
everything is connected. This AI can drive itself,
understands English, and can see an
understand the world around it too. Wow.
So now, are you thinking what I am thinking?
Oh yes, let’s give it a really hard time! Yes,
final boss time. Look at this
prompt! Experiment number two.
Let’s start following the red-black building until
we see a fire hydrant. And, haha, let’s get a
bit tricky! Yup, that’s right. No fire hydrant
anywhere to be seen. Your move, little robot!
And, look at that! It stops…turns around,
and goes the other way, and finally finds
that highly sought after fire hydrant. Very
cool. Now, into the grove to the right.
Okay, this might be it, and now, you are
supposed to take a right when you see a
manhole cover. No manhole cover yet, but, there
were ones earlier that it is supposed to ignore,
so good job not falling for these. And now,
the search continues. But, no manhole cover.
Still, not one in sight. Wait, got it!
And now, to the right, and find a trailer.
No trailer anywhere to be seen. Are we even at the
right place? This is getting very confusing. But,
with a little more perseverance, yes, there
is the trailer! Good job little robot!
This is absolutely incredible. I think this
description could have confused many humans,
yet the robot prevailed. All three
puzzle pieces are working together
really well. This looks like something
straight out of a science fiction movie.
And a moment that I really loved in this
paper, look. This is a scientist who is
trying to keep up with the robot in the
meantime. Imagine this person going home,
and being asked - honey, what
have you been doing today? Well,
I followed a robot around all day.
It was the best. How cool is that!
So, with DALL-E 2 and Stable Diffusion, we are
definitely entering the age of AI-driven image
creation, and with DeepMind’s AlphaFold,
perhaps even the age of AI-driven medicine,
and we are getting closer and closer to the
age of AI self-driving and navigation too.
Loving it. What a time to be alive!
And, before we go, have a look at this.
Oh yes. As of the making of this video,
only 152 people have looked at this paper. And
that, Dear Fellow Scholars, is why Two Minute
Papers exists. I am worried that if we don’t
talk about some of these works in these videos,
almost no one will. So thank you so much
for coming along this journey with me,
and if you feel that you would like more
of this, please consider subscribing.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!